hey guys Pete here this is going to be
my top moments video for Twin Peaks the
return part 11 which had a lot of
moments in it for me I don't know about
you guys quick spoiler warning if you
haven't watched episode 3 part 11 you're
going to want to stop watching this
video now check my playlist for Twin
Peaks videos on all the prior episodes
so yeah as mentioned there are a bunch
of moments in this I shot away from
saying things like this is the best
episode yet because they're so buried
what I will say is this was an awesome
ride this particular episode I really
enjoyed it so let's jump right into it
first big moment for me was Miriam it
saw some kids playing catch it had that
feeling that they're going to find
something or something's gonna happen
and it was Miriam one of those cool
scenes where you know something is gonna
happen you're not sure what it is so
it's really kind of hanging on the end
of your seat and like I mentioned in my
10 things you might have missed video
there was a definite possibility that
Miriam wouldn't be dead and sure enough
she's still alive
the next big moment was Becky's freakout
she's hysterical in her trailer she
calls up Shelley at the Double R she
needs a car she lies and says it's
Stephen and that he's hurt so Shelley
drives straight over before she gets
there Becky grabs a gun from under the
couch she comes out right away when
Shelley pulls up takes the keys jumps in
the car and then as he's driving off
Shelley jumps on the hood of the car
Shelley's red shoes play a big part here
like they you know you can't help but
notice them and when Becky throws her
off the hood carefully I guess in the
sense of you know she waited till she
got to a grassy area we see Shelley's
shoes fly off the next big moment was
called rod he comes over asked what's
going on and like a boss he just pulls
out this whistle I guess it's a whistle
and a Volkswagen van pulls up to take
them away like it was on call waiting
for his whistle so they take off down
the road she's calling Norma and he
hears her say that you know why don't
you just call Bobby
and car
all jumps into action once again and
pulled out the CB and gets on the on the
switchboard over at the Sheriff's
Department so the next big moment I
think at least for me was that we find
out that Shelley is actually Shelley
Briggs we weren't really sure how that
all played out but it's pretty clear now
that she's no longer Shelley Johnson
she's Shelley Briggs we all know the
status of their relationship at this
moment but Becky is definitely their
daughter next big moment is the next
thing that happened Becky
ends up at an apartment building she's
screaming at a door the neighbor says
they just left she screams and then she
empties the guns clip into the front
door there's kind of a shaky view of the
hallway that takes us down around and
down some steps and we see the Stephens
they're hiding with another girl
the next big moment is the sequence of
events that happens in Buckhorn
we see a couple cars pull up we see that
in one we have Albert
Tammy Gordon and Diane make it out and
the second one we see that Hastings
there he's being escorted by Detective
Mac Lee Tammy figures out what he did
the last time he was there because
they're in the place where he saw major
break Gordon our approach we hear the
sound we see like a woodsman fade in and
out they see it too and then the next
big moment is that Gordon moves ahead of
Albert a bit closer to the house and we
see this vortex kind of thing open in
the sky things get distorted around him
but we see as it pulls back that nobody
else can see this except for him and
Albert who are inside the perimeter of
the yard there so we see a shot of some
woodsman in his vision I guess he could
call it and just as he's about to
disappear Albert grabs him and pulls him
back when when he does that this guy
goes back to normal
Albert says I guess we found out and
Gordon replies we sure did Albert the
next big moment is that Bruce
Davenport's body popped back up and it
is we find out marked with some
coordinates on her arm and then Diane is
sitting over smoking looking at the car
and we see another shot
Woodsman that goes in and out of sight
and we get the idea to Diane probably
sees it but I don't know if it's clear
if she's like oh yeah there's one of
those likes you know sometimes she's
seen before or if she's sort of in
disbelief
either way the next big moment is that
we see the detective he sort of gets a
shock he doesn't know what's happening
and then something happens and he gets
freaked out he gets out of the car we
see the other people come over he calls
for backup and we hear Diane
say there's no backup for this and we
see that the top half of bill Hastings
head is completely blown off and the
next big moment for sure which I'm sure
I'm guessing this is an instant twenties
classic here but after they all sort of
settle down a second Gordon looks in and
says he's dead so stuff is awesome back
in the Double R we see that the whole
break Bobby Briggs family is together
they're Becky is upset they're talking
about her situation with Stephen which
I'll get more into in the recap and
review but for now the next big moment
is that red shows up red the drug
smuggling guide helped me saw a few
episodes back and instantly Shelley
brightens up so they are together we
assume they definitely know each other
well and are intimate and poor Bobby man
he just looks heartbroken sitting there
and it is mysterious in a way like we
really don't know how this all got to
where it is but yeah Bobby looks really
hurt over the idea that Shelley has this
new guy and we know in the back of our
mind that he's the worst kind of guy
from what we've seen anyways we can't
linger too much on Bobby and his hurt
feelings because the next big moment
happens right away and we see that a
gunshot rings out a bullet comes flying
through the window everyone ducks down
and Bobby goes outside kind of the whole
time whenever he's moving I'm thinking
okay he's going to die they're not gonna
know where Jackrabbits palaces and all
this so it's pretty intense scene this
is crazy honking going on in the
background it doesn't stop anyways we
find out that it's a kid who found a gun
in the backseat of their minivan there
and he fired off the gun and the honking
doesn't stop so the next big moment
when Bobby finally goes around to ask
the woman to stop and this is another
thing that I'll have to get into and
much more detail in the recap and review
but this woman's upset she is saying
things like we're late we have to go to
dinner wise it's happening her aunt is
coming over and she hasn't seen her for
quite some time and she sick and at
first we don't see anything whenever
this is happening we just see this woman
and wonder what who she's talking about
and then the next big moment is that
this person who I guess is a woman a
young woman it's hard to tell honestly
but she pops up and she's puking and
like peeking everywhere and she looks
like a zombie I mean I don't know a
better word to describe what's happening
here and I'm gonna leave it as that I
mean we all saw it and that is the
moment this kid or woman and their young
woman or whatever puking in the
passenger seat Bobby's look on his face
and then we just cut over to the 20
Sheriff's Department where we see Frank
Truman and ha so the next big moment
there is Hawkes living math that he
pulls out so he says that the
information that Briggs gave them got
them thinking and it'll start to make a
lot more sense when he explains his maps
so he has this map he's it's very old
that always stays current it's like a
living thing he points out we're you
know listening post alpha is Briggs
sedation on blue pine mountain he says
it's a very revered and sacred site he
shows them some symbols the campfire but
that's not really fire it's a fire
symbol like a type of fire like
modern-day electricity we see corn which
is supposed to be fertility but it's
black which means it's disease a natural
death
and then he says if you put these two
symbols together you get this which
Truman says black fire but we get no
description beyond that then the next
big moment is that Frank asked about the
symbol that we've seen on Briggs paper
and on the ace that evil coupe had way
back and Hawk just says you don't ever
want to know about that never so the
next big deal is that Margaret Lanterman
the log lady calls on the phone they
have a quick back in
fourth she asked what's going on he says
it's just like he said I'm sorry I
should have let you know she asked him
what he found she says I can't tell you
that
then she says my log is afraid of fire
there's fire where you were going hawk
there is fire where you're going
so definitely mysterious we don't find
out anything for sure there and again I
look at this a lot closer in the next
video back in Buckhorn we see that
Gordon tan is shaking a lot he's they
called it a Cat on a Hot Tin Roof it's
never happened or this has never done
this before they look at the picture of
Ruth's body they look at the coordinates
it sort of looks like Diane's trying to
memorize them because she's mouthing
them as they're looking but Albert tells
us that the last numbers are smudged so
they don't know for sure where it is
next big moment is to get them talk
about the woodsmen they mentioned that
they saw the one the shadowy one when
they first got there to the location
Albert said he looked like a homeless
man with a beard and this kind of
triggers Diane into the next big moment
where she says she might have seen
something like that getting out of the
car but died matically says I was in the
car and then she just backs off so she's
doing shady stuff of the forest and for
the most part for the scope of this
video we'll leave that whole situation
there then we go back to Dougie's office
where the first big moment for me there
was that you know Fallon Budd calls them
into his office but Phil the coffee guy
answers and he's like yeah I'll bring
him over
the first big moment there was him
luring dougie coupe with the coffee to
get him over there so they get over
there and we get a little bit of info
about what's going on Bushnell was
basically figured out that you know
something's going on and it's tied to
organized crime and possibly law
enforcement he ends up telling that you
know Dougie cooped at the Mitchum's have
gotten screwed over here they're not the
ones that are calling the shots and he
set up a meeting with him and them and
he'll be delivering a thirty million
dollar check so on the way out the next
big moment of course was Mike we see
Mike appear to dougie coupe sort of on
the right side
the building and a different I don't
know what it was a shop I guess Dougie
heads over there then we see him getting
put into the car by Bushnell and now
he's got a box so we find out that Jim
Belushi has had a dream and is bothering
Rodney Mitchum on the other hand is very
pumped up to kill dougie so they get out
to the site in the middle of nowhere of
course since dougie coupe doesn't do
anything he doesn't resist the idea that
he's being taken to a secret meeting in
the middle of the desert and we get to
the next big moment where hey if he's
got this one thing in this box we have
to not kill him he's on our side he's
not our enemy so there's all this
anticipation and then we see Rodney say
is that a cherry pie in that box they
look inside sure enough it is
they also frisk dougie so they find the
thirty million dollar check in all the
sudden Doug he's their best friend so
they head to a restaurant and the final
big moments all come here dougie to
Rodney and Benjamin all sit down the
Mitchum's are very excited we see dougie
respond to the music a little bit
differently
he almost looks like he's coming out of
it a bit there's sort of that feeling
hanging over the whole meeting like it's
something going to happen here he drink
some alcohol that seems to have an
effect on him in some way or another we
get a cameo from the lady slot addict
it's a Miss mr. jackpots woman didn't
know that she's doing better now we get
sandy candy and Mandy
once again candy sort of steals the show
for a minute was her strange behavior
that somehow super compelling at the
same time you just really want to know
what's going on with her the Mitchum
brothers are fantastic I really like
this pair I mentioned that in the last
video they're they're fun to watch as
they're sitting there and all this is
going on the Cherry Pie is presented and
it looks like they all gloriously enjoy
it as they sit there and the piano
player plays so yeah I'm going to cut
this short right now I want to jump
right into the recap and review I got to
do a rewatch and add to my notes it was
like writing a book taking Post hunters
but super
on episode 1 of the most horrifying
episodes in the first half but then
switches gears and becomes totally fun a
lot to think about talk to me in the
comments and let me know what you're
thinking about so that I can put some of
that stuff into the recap and review
awesome blue rose feeling stuff with
Gordon Albert and Diane
so yeah let's leave it there please like
the video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel follow me on
Twitter and hit me up over there and all
my other social media accounts my
Facebook page and my Instagram account
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon
you